and whenever she would try to speak out
she was savagely beaten
and she was never allowed to speak
and one of the reasons peggy was
determined to testify was that so she
could tell the truth that her mother
even though it's a different trial
but her mother was never allowed to
speak the truth and peggy felt that she
had to do this
for her mother
and what is peggy morgan doing today
peggy is living in the area and she's a
force in her neighborhood for cleanup
she plants trees and she's raising her
grandchildren
any other non-fiction books in the works
oh
i don't know you know it's it's a great
lure because of my journalistic
background because true stories can be
you know
equally as challenging as as fiction so
i won't say no to that but i'm not
working on anything right now
carolyn haynes my mother's witness the
peggy morgan story thank you for joining
us today
and book tv is live right now at the key
school in annapolis maryland for the
annapolis book festival our coverage
continues now with journalist and new
america foundation fellow peter bergen
the author of holy war incorporated
continues his investigation of al qaeda
with an oral history the book is called
the osama bin laden i know this is live
coverage of the annapolis book festival
on book tv on c-span 2.
may i repeat to the late comers that if
and when you have a question that if you
would walk to the center aisle where
there's a microphone so that your voice
uh will be heard and you get to be on
c-span
uh welcome
uh
i'm introducing peter bergen and i would
like to tell you that peter bergen is a
print and television journalist and
author of holy war inc
inside the secret world of osama bin
laden
holy war inc was translated into 18
languages and a documentary based on the
book was nominated for an emmy in the
year
2002. the washington post reviewed his
new book the osama bin laden i know an
oral history of al qaeda's leader free
press year 2006 calling it a detailed
well-researched narrative that
persuasively answers dozens of questions
that we're still painfully relevant
today
mr burgin is cnn's terrorism analyst and
an adjunct professor at the
school of advanced international studies
at johns hopkins university he has
written for the new york times
washington post vanity fair et cetera et
cetera numerous publications
and i'm very glad
that we're here to meet peter bergen
[Applause]
thank you very much um
can you all hear me this is good great
um
why write a book about osama bin laden
at all after all
isn't the osama bin forgotten at this
point uh isn't isn't he uh isn't he sort
of irrelevant and um i mean i guess are
two different kinds of arguments one is
is that
you know the global jihadist movement
which al qaeda set in motion doesn't
really need bin laden anymore uh he's no
longer in camarga command and control of
his organization
uh he you know he can't really order
operations in the way that he did before
9 11. i guess that's the conventional
wisdom and i i don't really buy it uh
for several reasons uh a i think that
bin laden remains uh an important
history an important historical figure
but i think he also remains an important
contemporary figure for reasons that
i'll explain
um
you know i believe in it perhaps an
unfashionable view of history that um
you know that certain people make a
difference and that uh it's very hard to
explain the holocaust without hitler
it's very hard to explain why the french
were in moscow in 1812 without napoleon
and it's impossible to understand how al
qaeda developed without reference to bin
laden's personality and world view
and to some extent of also if he's
number two ayman al-zawari
one of the discoveries i made in the
book and i'll get to it in a minute i'll
get in a minute to what i think will uh
why benign remains important today
one of the discoveries i found in the
book uh is in this new book uh the osama
bin laden i know is the actual founding
minutes of al qaeda's first meetings
among certain people would even become
fashionable to say that al-qaeda really
didn't exist there was really no
organization it was just a group of
like-minded jihadists who gathered
together in afghanistan bin laden wasn't
really that important to them
there was a bbc documentary which even
suggested that al qaeda was really a
construct of u.s law enforcement uh in
an effort to start prosecuting people
they adopted this mafia model of
al-qaeda with bin laden as the boss
um and and we're using that as a
prosecutor prosecutorial device
well of course al qaeda is not a fiction
of uh u.s law enforcement as a as a bbc
documentary uh claimed
uh and in fact it's been an organization
from its very inception run in a rather
top-down fashion by osama bin laden
the minutes of these meetings uh these
first al-qaeda meetings were actually
found in bosnia
in a raid on a charity called
benevolence international foundation
which is a charity which has long been
supportive of jihadist causes and this
raid happened in 2002.
the notes uh that were discovered in
this raid uh
related very much to bin laden's early
history in founding al-qaeda and we can
now actually date the founding meetings
of al qaeda and we can sort of see what
they discussed it it took place
uh august 18th uh 19th and 20th 1988
in bin laden's house and basically what
had happened is that milan realized he
had this trained cadre of people and the
soviets it was pretty clear were about
to leave afghanistan and uh you know he
wanted to do something else with them
and he was going to find that found this
thing called al qaeda and it was only
founded interestingly only 15 people
founded this organization and we had the
names of these people in these minutes
and what's interesting is
the um the actual day they launched uh
operations by their own account was
september 10th at 1989
which is interesting because only uh
11 years later pretty much exactly
they conducted the 2001 attack on
washington and new york
why is that to me that's interesting
because this rather small group of
people within a decade have turned
themselves into the world's most
effective terrorist organization
and i think that a lot of that is down
to bin laden's leadership unfortunately
let me back up and let me explain why i
think he's important today and then let
me go chronologically through some of
the things i found in the book which i
thought were interesting or new or
perhaps unexpected um
binary remains important today because a
we haven't found him seven out of seven
out of eight americans think it's very
important to find bin laden
uh it would obviously be an enormous
psychological victory in the war and
terrorism to find him capture him or
kill him
but more than that ayman al-zawahiri and
bin laden between them have released
more than 35 videotapes or audio tapes
since 9 11.
and i want you to think about that
figure because it's really quite an
astonishingly large figure it's a one
every six weeks
and obviously the easiest way to find
these guys at the chain of custody these
audio tapes they don't just magically
appear at al to zero they are brought
there by people and whoever whatever the
process is that they're getting from
the afghan pakistan border to al jazeera
usually
is a process that is traceable yet with
all the hundreds of billions of dollars
we spend on our national security
uh we seem unable to stay to uh to um
to stake out al jazeera's bureau in
pakistan which has been the recipient of
the number of these tapes
why these tapes important well they do
two things
uh first of all they pump up the base
and they continue to you know tell al
qaeda and its affiliates
to attack americans to attack westerners
to kill jews
but more importantly
they actually have specific instructions
on these tapes
i'll give you a few examples ayman
al-zawari al-qaeda's number two called
for attacks on president musharraf in
pakistan
in september 2003 within about three
months he had two very serious
assassination attempts military
dictatorships don't tend to have very
good succession plans uh you know if
if president musharraf suddenly
disappeared uh that would be a big
problem i think uh for the war on
terrorism broadly speaking
bin laden's called for attacks on saudi
oil facilities in december 2004 we just
saw a very serious attack against the
saudi oil facility which likely didn't
work out arguably the most important
facility in the world
several weeks back
i think there's some connection between
bin laden's calls for these attacks and
these things actually happening bin
laden's repeatedly called for attacks on
members of the coalition in iraq i think
that's one of the reasons we had the
attack in spain killing 191 people and
it's obviously one of the reasons we had
the attack in london killing 56 people
in july 2005.
so bin laden remains relevant not simply
because every day he's at liberty as a
sort of propaganda victory for al qaeda
but but because through the medium of
these videotapes and audio tapes he
keeps actually influencing what the
jihadists do in fact the most reliable
guide to what the jihadists do has
always been what amen what bin laden
says and to some degree what am i zawari
says
and i think a mark of their significance
is the fact if you look at what zakari's
doing in iraq
to some degree zakari the main insurgent
commander in iraq is taking cues from
al-qaeda i'll give you three examples
one
he renamed his group al-qaeda in iraq in
2004 and he pledged allegiance very
publicly to bin laden
zawahiri al-qaeda's number two sent him
a letter which u.s military intercepted
uh on in the letters our here he's
telling zukawi enough with the
beheadings you know this is turning
people off we're not connecting with the
masses and in fact zakari has stopped
the beheadings it's hard for me to prove
cause and effect but al qaeda's message
to zakari has been to stop the
beheadings to connect with the masses
and if you think about the most recent
zakari videotape it's the first time
that we've really seen him uh without a
mask and without you know a knife about
to behead somebody it was a kind of sort
of gentler fuzzier kindler uh kind of
zukawi if that's possible and uh
he um
now he's ignoring one part of the advice
that al qaeda is giving al qaeda has
said we don't want any al qaeda's
leadership in in afghanistan pakistan
has said we don't want any part in a
shia sunni civil war i'm sure bin laden
privately thinks that she is our
heretics but he doesn't want he's never
said anything negative about iran or
shiism i think partly because he wants
to speak for all muslims but more
importantly uh his son and a number of
the top leaders of al-qaeda are under
some form of house arrest in iran today
and they don't want that to be
interfered with by some shia sunni
conflict
um so zukawi is to some degree you know
although he's ignoring part of the al
qaeda plan he's he does seem to he wants
to make himself part of al-qaeda he's
said that rather publicly and in fact on
the most recent videotape from zakawi he
talked about bin laden being the prince
the emir of the movement
he also actually spliced in videotape of
ibn and also iman al-zawari so the
reason i think they remain important is
that they continue giving ideological
and strategic guidance to this network
i also decided to write this book
because it was a lot easier to write
this book the the particular book i've
written uh after 9 11 before 9 11 for
several reasons
um getting into saudi arabia and talking
to people who knew bin laden became a
lot easier after may 2003 i think uh may
2003 you may recall was the riyadh
attack the first of 20 terrorist attacks
in saudi arabia the saudis have got a
very different attitude i think that
being much more open to journalists i
you know it's obviously it was very
close society
i was able to speak to bin laden's
friends and and some of his family
members uh in a manner i think that it
would be very hard to have got to be
able to do before 9 11. also we've had a
a blizzard of cases involving al-qaeda
leaders and
and associates uh since 9 11 and where i
couldn't talk to people directly a very
useful way of finding out what people
say are going to say is core testimony
and whether it's to some degree how they
check mohammed's i'll give you know
several examples sheikh muhammad's uh
the summary of his interrogations which
are introduced into the musabi trial are
incredibly interesting their public
record uh fairly easy to find now uh
that's the i'm never going to be able to
interview khalid sheikh mohammed
obviously who plays such a critical role
in the 911 attack but at least by
looking at the summaries of his
interrogations you get that's the
nearest anybody any of us are going to
get to actually getting a sense of who
this guy is and how he planned 911 but
there are cases around the world in
bosnia in germany and spain and france
in the united kingdom united states
canada which i drew on for this book
people who and the bar for this book i
call is the book is called the insider
bin laden i know the bar for the book
which may be an artificial one is that
only people who actually knew bin laden
or know him
in some manner
we're going to be heard from
and
it's it's a form of it's a device but i
think it's a sort of useful device
because i think that anybody's actually
met bin laden even briefly
as i did in 97
might have something to say or some of
the people i'm talking about people
who've spent um you know years and years
and i'll give you i'll start
chronologically what if you if you met
bin laden when he was
let's say 14 what would how would he
appear
well according to his best friend at the
time in his soccer playing buddy uh by
the name of khalid batafi
you know osama bin laden really stood
out as somebody was praying seven times
a day two two more times and is
necessary uh he was fasting twice a week
modeling himself and the prophet
muhammed again something that is not
required in islam but was was additional
he um
he was uh doing religious entertainment
for the poor of uh of jeddah uh you know
really kind of a rather admirable guy a
sort of priggish almost uh almost a
religious a religious zealot to some
degree uh rather priggish telling his uh
his half brothers not to look at the
maid uh very being very kind of uh
aggrieved when this best friend of his
soccer playing charm was wearing shorts
because they aren't modest
dress
and so i think if you met him when he
was in the 14 15 year old uh time frame
he would just strike you as this rather
um you know he st he stood out as
somebody his religious zeal stood out
even in saudi arabia
in the mid 70s he was attending a
european influence school he was not
going to madrasa some of the things that
one of the messages i'd try and make
point out is that madrasa graduates do
not produce terrorists there's just no
correlation between that if you look at
the the major anti-western attacks uh in
uh terrorist attacks uh madrasa
graduates don't feature at all in them
and of course bin laden himself didn't
go to a madrassa he went to a rather by
saudi standards at the time a very
advanced european influence school
called al fager again i hear from one of
the people in the book it was his
english teacher as an english citizen
lived in saudi arabia for 10 years he
remembers osama rather well because this
guy was literally outstanding he was
much taller than his his other
classmates a rather shy modest retiring
guy that's the you keep hearing this
thing about this is not somebody who
really stood out who wanted to bring
attention to himself it was well known
that he came from this rather well-off
family
one of the things i discovered in the
book i really hadn't for obvious reasons
it's very hard to sort of work out the
family structure in saudi arabia
particularly because
you know talking about the female
members of the family is is completely
you know sort of verboten um and you
know saudi is a very close society and
the bin laden family is a very secretive
family uh but one thing i find i worked
out which i hadn't understood before is
that bernard is actually an only son
what to make of that i don't know but
it's simply a fact uh he he his mother
was one of 20 mothers that
the father mohammed bin laden married he
married them sort of in sequence uh
where you know you're only allowed to
have four so he'd keep divorcing why
three and four and he had 20 20 wives in
general and one of the interesting
stories in the book is um
jamal khalifa who's a very intelligent
guy who has bin laden's
both best friend at university and also
his brother-in-law they had a discussion
about polygamy uh and this that was
quite a surprising thing when he told me
this but i um jamal khalifa said that
when osama bin laden here were about 17
that it's this disgust about how to live
uh you know to to live polygamous life
in a sort of appropriate manner and they
both agree that their fathers had
married far too many wives bin laden and
jamal khalifa agreed that they would
only marry four wives and that there
would be no other new wives that would
be introduced into that and bilaam
basically stuck to that except
he offered his wives in sudan in the mid
90s a deal basically saying look life is
going to be pretty tough at this point
by the way you know bin laden was a guy
with you know not mili he wasn't a
multi-gazillionaire but he certainly
inherited up to 20 million dollars in
sudan they were living without air
conditioning bin laden was sleeping on
the floor
um
they he was uh you know not not even
allowing his kids to drink cold water
and he was really living this monk-like
life and basically he offered uh
his wife's a deal saying this is how
life is going to be and one of his wife
left at that point in 96
and also his all the time abdullah also
left in 96 basically saying you know we
come from one of the richest families in
the middle east you know i'm not signing
up for this program i'm leaving and so
bin laden um
so bin laden uh had this interesting
conversation about polygamy with his
with his best friend jamal khalifa and
jamal khalifa is the next phase you know
bin laden probably it seems to join the
muslim brotherhood when he was in
university interestingly for those who
uh uh
syed ketub who's sort of the
the i don't know
the most important theoretician of jihad
uh the egyptian writer who was executed
in 1966
his brother mohammed could have actually
taught at the university of jeddah where
bin laden uh actually attended his
lectures so that's a direct connection
between bin laden and
psychiatri had a rather revolutionary
idea at least by implication which is
that um
you know that jihad's
that
the middle eastern regimes uh if they're
not ruling in a sufficiently islamic way
are effectively pagan regimes and and by
implications should be overthrown and
that that idea of course has had a
tremendous influence on al-qaeda and its
affiliates because basically
it's a way of saying that other muslims
are not really muslim and you can sort
of make that decision yourself and which
is one of the reasons that we're seeing
uh these attacks uh by you know of
course bin laden wants to bring down the
house of saud uh which he regards as
apostate so there was a sort of direct
intellectual link between saying
mohammed gutub and the fact that bin
laden took muhammad khattab's lectures
and you know by the accounts of his
friends who were also involved in the
muslim brotherhood at this time bin
laden you know took it even more
seriously than them in a sense i mean
there were no pictures in his house no
paintings
no listening to music jamal khalifa
tells a somewhat amusing story where in
the days before the remote control he
was a you know like bin laden a real
sort of islamic fundamentalist and so
when the music came up on the news they
would only watch news on television but
if there was any music on the news he'd
get his son to sort of turn it down sort
of in the pre-remote control era um and
so that he wouldn't be listening to
music which was haram forbidden now
jamal khalifa is an interesting guy
because he's really he he has sort of
left milan behind by his own account uh
the u.s government uh uh
certain governments have claimed that
he's been involved in terrorism but i
couldn't find any jurisdictions where
he'd actually been indicted for acts of
terrorism and he turned out to be a
rather good source about bin laden he
he married bin laden's one of bilan's
sisters by the name of sheikha
who liked bin laden was very religious
and uh
at a certain point traveled to
afghanistan to be with bin laden and was
kind of horrified by changes that he saw
in bin laden at the time
and this is where a lot of bin laden's
friends basically begin to leave him you
know bin laden 1979 is arguably the most
important year in sort of the last
century in the middle east if you think
about it it's the year that the
ayatollah khamenei came back
to iran it's the year that the islamic
militants took over mecca the the main
mosque at mecca it's the year that uh
the soviets invaded afghanistan and it's
the year that sadat signed a peace
agreement with israel
now bin laden the time is 22 and he's
already as i've indicated a very you
know a hugely you know religious guy and
you think about all these four things
happening at the same time anybody who
is in this frame of mind would see this
as an extraordinary moment
and so when the soviets invaded uh
afghanistan this was the first time that
the soviet union had uh
you know invaded a sovereign country uh
a sovereign muslim country and um you
know this really
made a dramatic impact on bin laden who
sort of
started traveling to pakistan you know
again he's a the picture of them at this
time
you know people would go into a meeting
with him for you know an hour or two and
he'd say three words he was a very sort
of monosyllabic retiring guy
but he started financing this magazine
called jihad magazine which was sort of
the in-flight magazine of the people
around bin laden and it was
i found one of the discoveries in the
book as i found i'd always known about
magazine but i found
um 10 volumes several thousand pages of
it in kabul and abused bookstore and i a
lot of i translated a lot of it um the
relevant parts for this book and bilal
doesn't feature very much in the in in
this in this mid in the 80s i mean he's
known by his
his sort of uh jihad jihad handle which
is abu abdullah um
and he shows up in the book and which is
interesting because of course the book
was written contemporary the g hat
magazine was written contemporaneously
and he shows up as somebody who was
actually fighting the soviets personally
and i had eyewitness accounts of that
but it's also good to have
contemporaneous uh written documentation
showing that's the case whatever
whatever else bin laden is he's not a
coward uh he certainly was fighting the
soviets directly in fact he was fighting
them suicidally uh suicidally bravely uh
he set up a military camp in a place
called jaji
right next to a soviet military post
and he was asked why are you doing that
well he said i want to attract enemy
fire now as a military strategy that's a
very poor one um and i think that
it really goes to the mindset of what
bin laden was really getting now he i
mean he really wanted martyrdom the
young arabs he was recruiting also
really wanted martyrdom
and when jamal khalifa went in 85 to
check out jaji himself or perhaps in 86
he was horrified because he knew that
his best friend bin laden had absolutely
no military experience
and he could see this was essentially a
kamikaze mission for all these you know
very idealistic uh mostly saudi
university students who were coming to
afghanistan to fight under bin laden's
control
and basically had a huge bus stop with
him and they didn't ever they only met
one more time maybe in 1990 and they and
a lot of bin laden's friends all had the
same critique of this because they knew
bin laden wasn't a military guy
they knew that he what he was doing
extremely dangerous and didn't make any
sense from a military point of view not
just simply that it was suicidally
dangerous but bernard want to bring all
the arabs in afghanistan into one unit
sort of under his control and his former
his mentor abdullah zam who is this
palestinian cleric who had some
involvement in the founding of hamas had
a very different view one of the
discoveries in the book i always thought
that azam
well i knew that islam was benign's
mentor but i didn't understand that they
actually had this huge split islam would
actually be assassinated in bashar in
1989 very probably by people not that
the new bin laden i'm not saying that
bin laden was involved in the
assassination but the people who
actually the my source on that is a
surprising one if the egyptian militants
in peshawar at the time tell me that
they think it was people in the egyptian
militant circle uh people like ayman
al-zawari who basically wanted bin laden
to kind of go over to this much more
radical idea about attacking middle
eastern regimes now abdullah zam who was
really the guy brought all these people
into pakistan in the first place was a
fairly extraordinary guy a great orator
you know everybody by all accounts kind
of an amazing person
uh
now his idea was a sort of traditional
fundamentalist notion of jihad which is
we're going to get non-muslims out of
formerly muslim lands whether that's
afghanistan whether that's the former
soviet union uh whether that's in in
andrew lucia as azam wanted you know
andy lazier of course 500 years ago i
was muslim so
but the people aiming
the people the egyptian jihadists who
actually began influencing bin laden in
this period
uh they wanted to also overthrow regimes
around the middle east and now bin laden
wanted part of that at that time
but he became more radicalized in his
arm
and he began having this quiet split a
carefully concealed but real split
and that split culminated in november 89
when azam was killed assassinated in
peshawar and i think that azam if his
arm had still been alive that might have
been a counterweight to bin laden
because islam had so much more spiritual
authority than any of these people uh
but he was gone and uh and of course
around about the time that azam was
assassinated of course the soviets were
gone from afghanistan so that goes back
to the al qaeda meeting the first
meeting that i talked about earlier
so you know bin laden saw the soviet
withdrawal coming and he was going to do
something else with these guys and he
wasn't really sure what it was yet
what he really wanted to do with these
guys
uh in the 89 90 period was to liberate
yemen
that's kind of an odd thing if you think
i mean because we don't think of yemen
as a place that needs liberation but you
may remember that yemen was divided into
there had been a northerner north and
south yemen and the south of yemen was
controlled by socialists and so of
course bin laden is from hadramaw which
is in yemen his family so he had a kind
of strong desire to get involved in
defeating the socialists in yemen and uh
this was one of the things that the
saudi government was kind of not very
happy about because
even though you'd have thought the saudi
government would be against communists
and socialists towards that in that in
southern yemen sort of on principle in
fact they the saudi government was quite
happy that yemen was actually divided
because they didn't necessarily want a
united yemen on that border and they
certainly didn't want a private citizen
citizen like bin laden sort of running a
private foreign policy and getting
involved in in attacking uh people on
the southern border so that was the
beginning and bin laden starts turning
against the saudi government one of the
stories in the book is in 1987 there was
a apparently famous picture of king fahd
and queen elizabeth ii in which queen
elizabeth ii gave him king fired a cross
a military decoration and this caused a
huge stink amongst certain
various fundamentalist harvests that
somehow king fard had you know taken a
christian symbol and therefore was an
apostate now in 87 bernard said this is
completely ridiculous stop talking about
this the saudi royal family is on our
side but i think when he returned to
saudi he began having second thoughts
and uh those second thoughts uh
morphed into you know real real dislike
of the saudi royal family when he
famously offered
his troops to fight saddam hussein after
the invasion of kuwait that offer was
turned down and 500 000 u.s troops were
introduced instead and that of course
was the beginning of bin laden's real
rampage against the united states billan
has always been anti-american uh in a
kind of
not you know yeah even in the 80s for
instance he was refusing to drink pepsi
and refusing to drink sprite and sort of
boycotting american goods because of its
support for israel but that sort of
general dislike of the united states
morphed into real hatred as a result of
uh the operation desert shield and then
operation desert storm with us troops
actually in the holy land by his account
and
so in terms of the radicalization of bin
laden obviously the afghan war was
critical um basically ignoring the
advice of his mentors and friends about
creating this arab military force
um you know you know the rest of the
story i mean the sense that uh
it uh you know al-qaeda from small
beginnings um
you know was able to do a sort of uh
geometrically progressing kind of uh
arc of violence
i found probably the first act of
international terrorism that al-qaeda
ever engaged in which was a surprise to
me
was the attempt to kill the king of
afghanistan in rome in november of 1991.
now the king of afghanistan as you may
recall i think he's now sort of in his
early 90s even then he was a relatively
old man why would people in al-qaeda
circle want to kill the king of
afghanistan well they saw after the
soviet withdrawal the king of
afghanistan was the most popular
political figure in in afghan uh amongst
the afghan population and uh there was a
a moment when it seemed like he might be
brought back as sort of a you know some
sort of constitutional
monarchy uh you know some titular head
of state
and al-qaeda people saw him as a
secularist and uh a portuguese convert
to islam by a guy by the name of santos
he basically said look i'll go and kill
this guy
and uh bin laden didn't say no and
didn't say yes
uh at that time you know maybe al qaeda
was sort of you know just beginning and
less organized
santos goes to rome he stabs the king of
the king of afghanistan with them with
he pretends he's a journalist which is
interesting because that's how of course
how they kill like machama sued uh a
great afghan figure many years later
pretending to be journalists uh two days
before 9 11 they killed him with a with
a camera inside a bomb inside a camera
but so santos kills the king tries to
kill the king of afghanistan and uh i
love this detail the uh the blade is
deflected by a a cigar case that
he was carrying in his pocket so uh but
he did
i mean he did manage to cause him grave
injury and this is an old guy at that
time i think he was uh in his late 70s
um but that was really the first time
and then of course
they got engaged in somalia to some
degree and there's always been a debate
about to what extent was al qaeda really
involved in mogadishu um there are very
few things the u.s government and al
qaeda agree on is that al qaeda was in
somalia at the time that they were
training people with rocket
rocket-propelled grenades
and of course mogadishu is a interesting
thing to perhaps focus on because
let's pull back a minute from the
history and let's look at what bin
laden's strategy is
um
one of the themes in my book is that
he's a very he
he's a bright guy but he's actually a
rather poor strategist i mean whether
it's setting up the charging military
base
to attract enemy fire
or 911 itself which was a total disaster
one of them one of the surprises of the
book is how much internal criticism
there was within al qaeda about the 911
attacks for several different reasons a
um you know
well not i i know not not only within al
qaeda but also bin laden's former
friends and and colleagues many of them
of course said the attacks were against
islam but a lot of people had a a a lot
of the analysis is and these are
al-qaeda insiders that i uh um were
writing in arabic language newspapers in
a very public manner after 9 11 and some
of the people that
had gone to the training camps in
afghanistan that i interviewed and they
said look this thing this attack was a
tactical success in a sense but a
strategic disaster we had a good thing
going with the taliban in afghanistan
this was the first really islamic state
in modern history in our view um you
know al-qaeda's all these guys are on
the run anybody's ever uttered the word
jihad has got this 800-pound gorilla
called the united states going after it
and it was a mistake
um and
i i think that one of one of the themes
that i'm trying to
say to you i think is that bin laden
he's certainly a big thinker but he's
got he's made some rather
uh poor analyses uh strategically and
particularly about the united states and
the reason mogadishu figures into this
is that
bernard's analysis of the united states
behavior is based on somalia
it's based on vietnam somalia uh beirut
um these are the three things and uh he
sees the us pull out from somalia after
the 18 american servicemen were killed
the u.s pulled out of beirut after the
241 uh marines were killed in 1983. he
sees us as the model for u.s foreign
policy which is essentially you
basically you know send enough body bags
back to the united states and the united
states is going to fall well we're not
going to withdraw from washington or new
york clearly and um you know
the attack succeeded much
much better than bin laden thought
um and it provoked a kind of it provoked
a very unexpected response we didn't do
a soviet-style invasion of afghanistan
there were only 300 americans on the
ground at any given moment during the
afghan war 300 american soldiers um and
we overthrew the taliban rather handily
and there was no guerrilla war against
us
uh and uh instead of sort of withdrawing
from the middle east we seem to be you
know grabbing over bigger chunks of it
so it it his analysis of the united
states i think has been rather poor and
that may not be surprising
uh bin laden may have visited sweden in
the book i have a swedish hotel owner
saying that she remembers bin laden
coming to sweden on two occasions in
1970 and 1971 with his older brother
salim a very different guy by the way
silent bin laden uh he uh he was the
head of the family when after mohammed
bin laden's father died and aged when
milan was 10.
i'm not as you know psychiatrist
obviously if your dad dies when you're
10 that would have some impact on you
although interesting enough it might not
because when you've got 54 siblings it
was i mean when they met the father it
was like a state visit it wasn't like
you know warm and fuzzy family reunion
it was a different kind of thing and
most of the brothers really didn't know
bin laden because they didn't see him
much there was different families
different houses and then most many of
the brothers had you know didn't really
see their father very much because he
was rather distant figure by all
accounts a very bright businessman um
and
uh somebody who was you know getting his
hands dirty in the family business and
driving the bulldozers in fact bin laden
himself did the same thing
where was i going
[Laughter]
um say what
sweden oh yeah lack of analysis the
united states um he
you know he has he hasn't visited the
united states he doesn't really his
knowledge of the united states or the
west in general is is entirely secondary
now ayman al-sawari al-qaeda's number
two did unbelievably come on fundraising
trips in the united states in the early
90s fundraising fundraising trips you
know for effectively for al qaeda in
california
um
but bin laden doesn't really know the
united states and he you know one of the
criticisms uh about 9 11 that some of
these al qaeda insiders were saying is
that yeah and i guess the morals here is
never believe your own propaganda is
that bin laden
kept you know he was saying the united
states was a paper tiger somalia
mogadishu vietnam and there were a group
of arabs who'd visit the united states
younger guys who were sort of these yes
men who kept saying to bin laden yeah
you're absolutely right just hit him a
couple of times they're going to be yeah
they'll be out of the middle east and of
course that analysis proved to be very
wrong
you know what um
i'll stop for questions in a second i'm
trying to think about some sort of final
thought that uh i mean what i i i
i think that bin laden's
other weaknesses um the other strategic
strategic weaknesses that these groups
in general have are two
one is that they keep killing a lot of
muslim civilians and this puts them in a
sort of in a double bind because a the
koran is quite explicit about you know
in times of war you can't
bring down trees you can't destroy roads
you can't kill civilians etc and of
course killing muslim civilians is sort
of a double whammy and um
we've seen i think some
it takes bombs to go off in particular
countries for this reaction to happen
arguably it took 911 for the united
states to focus on this problem um
but you know in the second round of bali
attacks in indonesia in november and
2005 which killed only indonesians uh
that i was i was there shortly after
that happened it provoked a a very
strong reaction from indonesians in
general and indonesian clerics basically
saying this idea about
this al-qaeda affiliate called jamaice
lamia which is in indonesia you know
we're gonna basically clerics were
saying we're going to write our own
books about jihad we're going to explain
how these people have hijacked this idea
we saw that same reaction in jordan
after the attacks on the hotels you know
100 000 people took to the streets to
protest this we saw that attack after
london there was universal condemnation
of the london attacks if you think about
jill carroll you know clerics from
around the muslim world muslim leaders
uh wrote and expressed their desire to
get her released and so i think that
there seems to be a sort of a bit of a
sea change and you know even al qaeda's
got it i remember the zawahiri zakari
letter enough with the beheadings and
they've stopped the beheadings it's like
there are things that are you know the
the things that are one of them so their
problem is that they have not been
uh that they continue killing muslim
civilians and by their own account we're
not connecting with the masses zawahiri
says that in his biography you know we
haven't connected with the masses there
was a really interesting poll in saudi
arabia that by the way when i say that
i'm not just not to say that bin laden
is not a popular figure in the much of
the muslim world we know the you know he
had a 2000 in 2004 he had a 65
favorability rating in pakistan it's
down to 33 right now so you know these
things can change uh and i think one of
the reasons that his numbers have gone
down in pakistan is because the us
helped with the earthquake relief
you know our numbers which are in the
tank in a lot of countries in the muslim
world for obvious reasons uh do improve
dramatically not by sort of saying
uh we're good people or sending karen
hughes you know to say we're good people
whatever it is but but by actually doing
things i mean we know in our own lives
that's what people do to us not what
they say to us that actually counts and
so
one of the kind of optimistic things
is what happened in indonesia not just
with a bali number two attack which
basically turned a lot of indonesians
against these groups but u.s military
help in this with a tsunami
changed a lot you know anti-americanism
really went down views about the war on
terrorism uh went in the right direction
indonesia so we saw in indonesia and
pakistan that the anti-americanism can
change given you know if we actually
sort of seem to be actually helping
um but so al qaeda gets it that they're
not connecting with the masses um and
this interesting poll in saudi arabia i
think kind of encapsulates what a sort
of seeming paradox when saudis were
asked
what do you think of osama bin laden in
a poll about two years ago fifty percent
of them said they liked the guy when
they were asked do you want to live in
osama bin laden controlled country only
five percent said yes and i think that's
a very telling because i think most
muslims don't want to live in a taliban
style theocracy stretching from
indonesia to morocco which i think is
basically what bin laden bin laden wants
now one this gets so the muslim civilian
problem that they're killing they keep
killing because they regard anybody uh
you know they have their own sort of
theology in a sense that muslim
civilians who you know might get killed
in these attacks
uh are probably apostates if they were
going to let's say an american-owned
hotel in jordan uh but i this is not and
so they recognize they're not connecting
with the masses and the name of zerari's
biography he says we need to we need to
really hammer our home on the
israel-palestine issue because even
people who aren't don't believe
you know in
even people who are arab christians or
secularists this is a this is something
we can all get around but i think this
is a little bit late because i think
that most people have kind of got what
al qaeda's real message is about
um
and so not connecting with the mass is a
problem and then the other part of the
problem which is sort of related
uh is we know what assam bin laden is
against but we don't really know what
he's for i think i mean i can tell you
you you know what he's against um
what is he for i think when he's asked
directly what is he for he would sort of
say
um a clash of civilizations he's been
asked this directly um you know that i'm
trying to provoke juan
um maybe these pants people are fans of
samuel huntington's work because they
really believe there is a clash of
civilizations which their view version
of islam is going to win
and he also i think we'll talk about the
caliphate now the likelihood of the
caliphate sort of re-emerging i think is
like the holy roman empire re-emerging
in europe it's you know it's a
rhetorical idea it's not something that
can really happen
but it's a but it's it's a
rhetorical idea with you know some
degree i guess people have
it
it
it exercises a fair amount of control
over people in the jihadist movement but
what would that caliphate look like i
think it would be taliban style
theocracy from indonesia to morocco and
so that is the second part of the
problem they one of the reasons we won
the cold war is that we had uh you know
we just were looked like a much better
option than the soviet union and i think
that i think most muslims if we look if
we take that saudi arabia poll where
only five percent want to sort of bin
laden controlled state kind of get it
that while while billan is popular
basically because he stuck it to the
west
i think there is a silent majority of
muslims who have already rejected much
of much of bin laden's
world view
thank you
[Applause]
any questions
well that's makes my life easy
but i think you need to go to the mic
thanks
hello
can you give us your impression of the
zarkawi tape that just came out this
first videotaped
interview and whether you thought it
actually
hurt or helped his cause
and then what you thought of the us
military's reaction where they're trying
to discredit his appearance in the video
well i mean if it works um taking your
second question first i mean if it if if
this thing you know that as you may know
the u.s military found the outtakes of
the zakawi tape the one that we showed
him shooting this machine gun and and in
the outtakes he doesn't really know how
to use it this machine gun and it's like
it's much less competent than it
appeared the first time but then u.s
military officials performer are saying
well actually that's a source machine
gun which is american machine gun it's
actually kind of complicated to use and
it wouldn't necessarily be surprising
that he doesn't know how to use it but
look i mean anything that can puncture
these you know these people are
operating sort of as mythic
personalities and anything that makes
them turns them back into human beings
you know our public diplomacy has been
terrible but the genius thing that we
did with saddam hussein checking him for
head lice and you know that was real
public diplomacy at its best and
basically it took him from being this
kind of you know mythic persona and
transforming back into being into a
human being one of the zukawi tape in
general i mean
you know it seemed like a fairly
effective piece of propaganda it was you
know it showed zakari being active and
not beheading people and uh you know um
giving orders to people and uh uh
and
and it did and it also you know to me as
i indicated earlier i think it by
mentioning bin laden by name by
incorporating videotape of him and of
aiming sawari zakari was trying to also
say that i am part of this larger
network
you indicated that they regarded 9 11 as
a strategic error
do you think that accounts for
but to some degree
why there have been no attacks on the
continental united states since then
well i mean elements within al qaeda saw
it as a strategic error i mean other
people may have
uh seen it as a strategic victory and
you could make the argument that
you know by
you know producing this huge sort of
propaganda or the deed that bin laden
may have attracted people to the
jihadist calls i'm not sure
but why why hasn't there been an attack
here uh i mean i think it's very simple
really they don't have the people to do
it
um we're actually very we're relatively
you know we're in a very different
posture than we were uh on september
11th
the american dream which hasn't always
operated as it's supposed to in this
instance has worked pretty well american
muslims are disproportionately uh highly
educated they have higher incomes than
the average american
muslim americans voted actually uh
interestingly and ironically
in greater numbers for george w bush in
the first election than for the
democratic contender so this is a group
of people who is very well integrated
and
you know i think that american muslims
have rejected the al-qaeda ideology
societies that are built on immigration
like canada or
australia to a lesser degree but
particularly the united states are going
to be resilient to the al qaeda virus in
a way that european countries which are
not built on immigration and as we see
with madrid attack the london attack the
theo van gogh attack in holland and also
everything that's happening in europe
right now to a large degree the future
of al qaeda or these jihadist groups in
a sense is going to be being decided in
europe uh after all richard reed with
the so-called shoe bomber as a british
citizen we've had a belgian female
suicide attack in
uh conducting a belgian female
conducting a suicide attack in iraq in
november 9 2005 along with her husband
and so you know i'm not saying that we
should sort of say we're you know
obviously we're not safe from you know
al qaeda will want to continue to try
and attack us but i think the bottom
line is because of the nature of our
society
uh we are going to be more resistant to
this than most european
countries thank you
um
you are one of the
world's foremost experts on
osama bin laden and my question is
potentially compromising but given the
errors we've had in american
intelligence in the last
few years in particular my
what i was wondering is
to what degree are you do you share the
intimate information you have
with with the the western intelligence
organizations let me there's a very easy
way to answer that which is that um
the media is an information gathering
arm of the american public uh and it's
not the information gathering army the
american government and nothing that we
do we you know we don't keep like the
best stuff back
so you know i mean everything that i
know about it is most i put it in the
book i didn't keep like the secret best
bits back i mean so
so this you know i mean they're they're
booked by us too so
their access doesn't proceed the general
public's access to information well no
and what i mean i mean and also at this
point i mean what special information
could anybody offer about bin laden i
mean believe me if i knew where he was
right now i'd be on the phone getting
the 27 million dollar reward so
[Laughter]
i don't think you know the number of
people who actually know where he is now
is i mean i'm being facetious but i mean
there aren't there isn't
who in the world does have any really
good information about i mean the key
question would be where is he and i i
think the number of people who know the
answer to that question is probably five
or
six and the reason i use that that
number is the number of people actually
knew what was really going to happen on
911 within al qaeda itself was maybe you
know up to ten um you know so this is a
very secretive disciplined group of
people they don't you know it's not
they're not they didn't clue in the
so-called muscle hijackers about what
the plot was they you know
they just are very compartmented and uh
so you know there isn't really
particularly useful information uh about
bin laden's whereabouts that uh
very few people know where he is
where would what would you like to know
at this point where do you see your
your uh journalism going in terms of of
uh
the politics in the middle east and
well i mean i guess one way to answer
that is like what are the big
developments that are happening right
now that we need to be concerned about
and
um i've just been i've i've visited
afghanistan repeatedly repeatedly and
i've been there uh twice in the last
several months and we're in the we're
losing afghanistan which is a rather sad
phenomenon given the fact that it's a
country which is
uh we there are a lot of reasons for
optimism three million refugees returned
refugees don't go back to places that
they've left unless they really think
there's a future
very successful presidential election
parliamentary election but now the
security situation in afghanistan is
deteriorating very rapidly kabul looks
like i've never been to baghdad but like
how i imagine parts of baghdad look
there's more concrete barriers there's
more street closings the sad fact is
that suicide operations as we've seen in
iraq are incredibly effective and
they've been 30 suicide operations in
afghanistan that means that the ngos in
the south are basically pulling out it
makes
doing anything in the country much more
dangerous
uh so that's one thing one development
that's not good you know blow back from
the iraq war you know or the blow back
from the iraq wars because there may be
several wars that go on sort of
simultaneously within the country
it's not going to be good we've already
run the videotape once before and we
know what the flow back from the afghan
war is it was the world trade center
attack in 93 911 the u.s embassies the
uss cole why would the iraq war blow
back be any different in fact it could
be much worse the people like bin laden
were fighting one of the world's worst
armies in history this all-conscript
soviet army of the 1980s the zakaris are
fighting one of the world's best army in
history uh and um they're doing ieds and
suicide operations which would be very
transferable to
other acts of urban terrorism they're
swapping business cards they're getting
battlefield experience so
i'm concerned about that um and i'm also
concerned i'm concerned that we haven't
found bin laden for the reason we
indicated earlier it's like this is not
just he's not just a historical figure
um
so and i'm concerned about what's
happening in europe
you know because i think
we have a thing called the visa waiver
program with european countries which is
i'm not suggesting we change but it
means that you don't have to have a
sit-down interview with a consular
official as a european citizen to come
to this country and that means when you
go to britain or france you don't have
to go to you know it's vice versa i mean
if we changed it it would be much more
complicated for americans to travel in
europe but
you know that it is not an accident that
you know the so-called shoe bomber
richard reed was a british citizen i
mentioned the belgian female suicide
bomber you know there is a group of
people who are not being degraded in
europe uh they can travel this country
relatively easily when we get attacked
again i'm sure it'll be somebody with
hypothetically a british french or
spanish italian passport
um if you remember in tel aviv there was
an attack uh which didn't which really
kind of focused my attention on this in
2003 two british citizens pakistani of
pakistani descent conducted a suicide
operation in tel aviv now that's
extraordinary thing about british
citizens conducting suicide operations
in israel and of course then we had the
july 2005 attack
so this group of people you know also
they don't like their own governments
they don't like israel and they also
don't like us
so you could easily imagine a situation
in the future uh where the next attack
is conducted by a european
thank you thank you
um
you know zarqawi
and it's been recently exposed that
he's been he's very virulently and
anti-shia yes so uh do you think that uh
you know by aligning with him uh
al-qaeda is in a sense sort of marginal
and marginalizing itself
uh because now you've you know it's only
appealing to one segment which is the
sunnis rather than the shias and and
what do you think that that you know
what what will be the impact of that uh
well you know he um you know as i said
earlier al qaeda
doesn't want to provoke a sunni
sunni shia civil war
uh the al-qaeda leadership obviously
zakawi does so this is a point of
disagreement but on the other you know
if they're i don't think al-qaeda's
going to wash our hands as a kawaii
because ikawi's actually doing things
and the people on the leadership may be
influencing strategically
uh and inciting people but they aren't
actually killing americans which and
killing you know uh apostates in iraq
as uh as zakari is so i mean i don't
think there's going to be a split
between the many times this tape
indicated quite the opposite of a split
uh to me the most recent tape indicated
you know
a reaffirmation of their
alliance go ahead i think you have to
speak of the mic
uh you didn't mention iran i don't think
and i wondered
how that plays into the
civil war if that's what it is in iraq
yeah well i mean i've never been to iran
so i don't claim any expertise but um
yeah i will say that al qaeda uh
the military commander of al-qaeda a guy
by the name of seif al-adl
and the spokesman a guy by the name of
suleiman we write and um
and also bin laden's older sons by the
name assad they all live in iran under
some form of house arrest
and so i think zawahiri has always been
close to the iranians
um you know they're not
as far as they're concerned they don't
want any kind of shia sunni thing and
uh they haven't criticized iran
which is sort of interesting because you
may remember that iran and the taliban
almost went to war in
in fact i was there when was
when the war was going to happen
the taliban had killed nine iranian
diplomats and iran was massing on the
border so you would have thought that uh
that given that that al qaeda would be
very critical of iran but never have
they i've never heard bilan say anything
about iran really and we've got a lot of
stuff on the public record from him
go ahead
thank you um what do you think the
significance is of the masali conviction
i mean the significance is when we
didn't put the right person on trial i
mean it's at it it masawi you know
there's a lot of information that came
out of the trial but they couldn't the
al qaeda leadership couldn't couldn't
get this guy out of their hair fast
enough they're like this guy is a pain
he's uh you know he's difficult to deal
with you know let's like give him some
money and get him to go away in fact he
was in malaysia at one point hanging out
with some members of al qaeda and they
were
you know he was
doing all the things you're not supposed
to is kind of constantly calling people
on the phone when you're not like you're
supposed to
have some sort of phone security and he
was
you know would you want masali on your
team the offer to do anything you know
to organize a picnic or you know you
just wouldn't
you know he wasn't he wasn't so the
point is is that he had nothing to do
with 9 11. i mean nothing
and um
the real the real story to me is that we
don't have we have in our custody how
the sheikh mohammed and ramsay bin
al-sheeb who actually were the
operational commanders of 9 11. they're
never i think most americans will be
surprised that they are very unlikely to
ever
see the inside of an american courtroom
you know these are the people who
actually plan 911.
um and why why is it that they will
never see the inside of an american
courtroom probably if the new york times
is to be believed and i'm sure it's
right these people have been abused in
manners you know that what they've said
is all inadmissible and so when i've
asked people in the you know on the
legal side in the u.s government you
know what is going to happen with these
guys well they say well one day they
will see you know maybe there'll be a
military tribunal for them
but i'm not even i don't know anything
about the law but i don't think a
military american military tribunal
would find this stuff admissible i mean
these people seem to have been you know
abused in some fashion
and so the real story the misawa trial i
mean the masari trial is given way too
much freight because it's the only time
we're ever going to put somebody on
trial for the 911 events and that's why
you know i thought the jury did actually
a very kind of good job of actually
separating a lot of this stuff out
given that
bin laden is presumably losing at least
some support in among the arab masses as
you point out
that sounds encouraging but on the other
hand it also seems that there's a lot of
dissatisfaction with the iraq war and i
guess the the israel situation and
other
but i is that a statement or a question
well it's leading to a question which is
um
what do you think it's going to take to
essentially get the
the
muslim world to stop
doing suicide bombs and uh well trying
trying to destroy our civilization let
me let me answer it like this um
i mean i don't think the muslim world is
trying to destroy our civil civilization
it's an incredibly small group of people
who are reasonably intelligent who would
like to attack us um and who succeeded
once um
and you know i don't want to confuse
generalize anti-americanism with people
who actually want to kill us i mean
certainly we've created a lot more
anti-americanism as a result of the iraq
war but as i indicated earlier it's it's
that's very fungible i mean not fungible
it's it's it's amenable to change i mean
there wasn't there was a great deal of
love for the united states uh you know
in the middle east around the time of
the sewers canal crisis because
eisenhower basically told the brits and
the israelis and the french what to do
um and so you know it's really what we
do that influences that and so i don't
think anti-americans is a permanent part
of the political landscape um certainly
the iraq war is the 800 pound gorilla in
the room and while that's going on you
know there's going to be continued
anti-americanism but that's not just in
the muslim world i mean there were
million man marches in london and
in in lots of
other parts of the world against the
iraq war
so i think if you do the thought
experiment where the iraq war had not
happened you know these groups would be
pretty marginal now al qaeda was quite
damaged by
you know
as we now know from their own internal
discussions it's like after 9 11 we lost
the taliban we lost afghanistan we lost
our bases you know this idea that
somehow they're all getting together on
the internet is true but like it's it's
one thing to get together and exchange
emails it's quite another to actually go
to a training camp in afghanistan and
meet bin laden so you know they the the
new al qaeda is making a virtue of
necessity it's a more virtual
organization it's more internet based
but they're not capable of the 911
attacks
um
so iraq was sort of uh mike troyer who
ran the ci's bin laden unit you know
often says that if bin laden believed in
christmas this would be under his
christmas tree the iraq war and
certainly the iraq war has re-energized
al qaeda and its affiliates we're seeing
cases in in the united states of people
training to go and fight in iraq
american citizens
we're seeing cases uh all these are
small numbers so far but saying the iraq
war has really provoked a sort of global
jihadist movement
um and you know
that's all true but i will also say that
my view a total withdrawal from iraq
would be a disaster
because
look i'm looking at from al qaeda's
point of view
what is al qaeda's narrative about us
i've already explained it was the paper
tiger narrative somalia mogadishu so but
it's not just about or we don't want to
play under their narrative we also don't
want to play into their strategy what is
their strategy their strategy aiming as
worries laid it out in his biography
knights under the banners prophet we
need a state or part of a state
somewhere in the middle east
uh which by the way would be a lot
better than afghanistan which is on the
margins of of of in of the arab world as
they see it um and so you know central
iraq zakawi you know run zakari run
central iraq is a pretty unattractive
proposition so despite the fact that i
think history will judge the iraq war as
the most um hubristic counterproductive
and incompetently carried out enterprise
in a recent american history
that doesn't mean and it's not we're
naturally tempting to just wash our
hands of the situation
that i think would be very problematic
and we've got to kind of obviously the
us military presence has fed the
insurgency but we've got to on the other
hand it would a total withdrawal
would basically allow this place uh it's
not just a chaos argument it's more like
what would what does al qaeda want we
don't want to give that to them
after the
hamas victory zawahiri advised
hamas to continue with the armed
struggle
and
you know not to just do the political
route to continue with the armed
struggle
and hamas basically rejected that advice
flat out
so can you talk a little bit about how
actively al-qaeda is trying to
coordinate with other groups like hamas
and what should we take from the
rejection that hamas had well i take uh
hamas's rejection of al-qaeda's sort of
ideas totally at face value i mean why
would you i mean political advice from
anyone else's worry doesn't seem like a
particularly great you know source and
he um you know and that's you know hamas
has done exactly what al qaeda wishes
wishes would have done they connected
with the masses they actually they're a
political movement now al qaeda is not a
political movement in that sense
and um you know there's been never been
any connection with i'm
between hamas and al-qaeda hamas and
al qaeda and hezbollah sort of played
ftse together in lebanon in the early
90s but you know these groups have
return addresses and the last thing they
want is like
you know uh to have the you know some
kind of connection with al qaeda that
would provoke an
american response
so i take that rejection
completely of face value
i think this is going to be the last
question
it probably is the last question
one of the things i think i hear you
saying
is
uh we also have to evaluate our strategy
you're saying and i do agree that it's
premature for us to leave end mass
but it is certainly time for us to
reconsider the strategy if the strategy
is working
if we continue on
there's certain there are a number of
countries that are very unhappy with us
certainly a number of those countries
are in europe as well
and consequently until we really have a
change of strategy and some of those
strategies are now being discussed as to
having a potential
three-party state if you will or three
three
breakdowns of the state of iraq uh i
think it's still going to continue to go
on and the loss of life
we talk a lot about how many people
we're losing we talk very very little
about how many people are being lost of
the iraqi population well i agree
completely i mean while while it's true
that
the jihadists have a problem they keep
killing muslim civilians i mean
it's hard for us to take full advantage
of that because we've also killed a lot
of muslim civilians and i think we're
getting better at
not doing that and the u.s military is
quite careful but clearly that you know
just iraq yeah we know that the
president himself has said 30 000 iraqi
civilians have been killed so let's
presume that's the lowest number
um so i you know that that's clearly a
problem
um i mean what how do we fix our
strategy overall i mean i think the bush
administration actually has
you know basically
they've recognized that you know these
people aren't attacking us because of
our freedoms i mean they talk much more
about we're at war with a radical
islamic
group
uh they've also you know that we're
drawing down 30 000 american troops this
year probably yeah so the bush
administration is not you know they're
not this is not a
they
they're not going to necessarily admit
mistakes
directly but they are going to change
tactics over time
um
but with iraq you know the uh
you know we can either score an f or we
can score a c minus and it's not you
know it's what it's like what is the
least bad idea we can do there
uh unfortunately we're in that situation
but least bad ideas of what life is
really about uh famously i think winston
churchill said that democracy is the
least bad idea we've come up with so
this is what we are faced with in iraq
um and i'm not i i haven't you know the
three the tripartite solution that you
mentioned which has been
joe biden and and
wrote about the new york times this is
something that peter galbraith
uh was been talking about for years who
spent a lot of time with the kurds you
know maybe this would maybe this is the
way to go unfortunately
you know this is the outcome that might
happen after you've had years of civil
war it seems that the you know people
are just gearing 100 000 displaced
people in iraq right now i mean the
civil war is going on
um and you know once these things happen
they tend to have a life of their own
and we saw you know we've seen in bosnia
and we've seen in afghanistan once these
things are once the fire is lit